[Music]
do you know what halloween and home
buying have in common they both can be
scary not to worry las vegas real estate
now who is sponsoring this segment is
here to answer our questions let's
welcome back harvey blankfeld to the
show good to see you hey thanks for
having me back jason chef harvey today
you got your halloween spirit i'm
confusing everyone i'm just going to
cook up some real estate deals for
everybody there you go
so what is scary about being a
first-time homeowner you know there's so
many things the first is is do i have
enough money yes and and the answer to
that question is you don't need a whole
lot not as much as many people think
the average cost for closing a deal
right now here in southern nevada is
about three percent for the closing
costs and your down payment could be as
little as three percent also if you're a
veteran you don't need any down payment
that's good to know yes what about uh if
a lender would approve me i remember my
wife and i looking for our first home
and you're filling out this big
application it's very stressful yeah
that time you're waiting to get approved
it's very stressful and if you're in the
midst of a transaction it's extremely
stressful so you go into the transaction
get pre-approved make sure everything's
set in place beforehand and if you do
that it becomes a lot easier a lot less
stress and that's the thing to get
pre-approved before you start looking
absolutely not the other way around your
budget ahead of time as opposed to
looking at houses that might be slightly
outside or outside your budget yes it's
right it's a smart way to do it yeah
okay so what about repairs
you know it's a scary thing for people
to think about that they buy a home what
am i gonna have to deal with well in the
midst of buying the home we have you do
hire a professional inspector he'll go
in he'll look at the house he'll tell
you what problems may be there and then
maybe the seller's going to fix some of
that stuff for you before you even close
the deal so that is possible something's
in there there's a leak or something you
can ask the seller listen i want to buy
your home but fix this and if they say
hey i'm not going to fix that you don't
have to buy the home you can back out of
the deal if you want to can i go back to
those closing costs real quick sure
is there a way to negotiate it so the
seller
covers your closing costs that's still a
thing that's a great question of course
it is in certain markets it'll prevail
in other markets it won't right now when
you've got a strong seller's market it's
tougher to get sellers to cooperate with
that but it's it's getting back towards
neutral so there may be some
opportunities for it okay now how long
does the process take here in southern
nevada an average transaction takes only
about 30 days that's if you're
pre-approved ahead of time and you make
the deal about 30 days to close the
transaction something i didn't think of
um and that's quick to 30 days is fast
yes something i didn't think of is is
what comes with maintaining a home we
got in our home we're so excited and all
of a sudden like what power bills hoa
all these other things all of that stuff
and you know you have to anticipate some
costs involved home ownership is
different than renting the cool thing is
you can mitigate some of that with a
home warranty so you don't have any
major expenses home warranties will help
you out a lot with that and also it's
not as expensive as you think i mean
most of the repairs are pretty minor and
don't cost that much and now everyone
watching should we
contact a realtor when it comes to
buying homes i think so i mean and
especially a realtor who wears a chef's
outfit i just think that would be a
great idea i don't know i think it's
great right now because people in the
gym right now are not listening they
don't hear the volume they see you know
real estate and they see a chef and
frankenstein that's not right yeah we're
cooking up something strange here now
where's the market stand is it a buyer's
market seller's market what is it still
a seller's market but it's heading
towards neutral and so there's more
opportunities now for buyers than there
were several months ago so if you were
buyer frustrated a few months ago check
it out again now it's actually a little
bit better for you i love it harvey
you're so important appreciate it my
friend thank you oh look what he's got
frankenstein
he's the carrier top of real estate
thank you to las vegas real estate now
for sponsoring this segment for more
information call 702 201
or find them online at
lvrealestateradio.com thank you harvey